qu'est ce que vous savez sur xiaomi
qu'est ce que vous savez réellement
alors vous savez que c'est une marque de
smartphone vous savez qu'elle propose de
bons produits vous savez qu'à sept ans
qu'à la plus en plus de produits qu'elle
a des boutiques en france ça c'est cool
on sait également qu au début en tout
cas en france elle s'est fait connaître
par le bouche à oreille on pouvait
l'acheter sur des sites chinois
puisqu'elle est arrivée en france en
2018 mais qu'est ce que vous savez
réellement je ne sais pas si vous savez
beaucoup de chaussures shiomi en réalité
donc vous dévoiler aujourd'hui 10
secrets de xiaomi vous allez voir c'est
beau c'est croustillant riait de la faux
et vous allez apprendre plein de choses
[Musique]
alors xiaomi xiaomi alors à commencer
par le commencement xiaomi a été créé en
2010 c'est extrêmement récent c'est une
boîte qui a à peine 12 ans une des
boîtes qui vend le plus de smartphones
dans le monde qui aussi entre la
deuxième et la troisième place et qui
pourrait potentiellement un jour venir
détrôner sam s'ouvre en nombre
d'appareils vendus hockey déjà ça plante
le décor et on va commencer tout de
suite partout premier point sépare les
deux mini qui est autant la marque
s'appelle xiaomi autant on va souvent
mis pour le voyez en tout cas souvent au
niveau des noms des smartphones parce
qu'il s'appelait le xiaomi mis quelque
chose alors le nom me est parti lui en
2022 ayons l'utilisent plus mais pour
autant ça reste quand même une emblème
de cette marque alors mis ça veut dire
quoi ça veut tout d'abord dire 'mobile'
internet tout simplement en fait ils ont
choisi le nom me pour
l'internationalisation de la marque en
2014 mais me ça fait référence également
à mission impossible
ben oui parce que c'était pas hyper
évident pour une nouvelle marque arrivé
fraîchement en 2010 de se faire une
place dans un univers où il y avait déjà
beaucoup de monde sur le marché enfin
ils sont quand même arrivés en 2020 en
tant que deuxième constructeur pendant
le plus de smartphones dans le monde
c'est pas rien donc la mission
impossible je pense qu'ils y sont
arrivés mëme ça représente également des
caractères chinois le caractère du coeur
et de la propreté donc là la boucle est
bouclée on est bon de tous les côtés
deuxième pont va regarder les
partenaires fondateurs de xiaomi alors
bien évidemment la botte été créée par
lei jun en 2010 mais y'a pas plus
derrière il y avait également un fonds
d'investissement de singapour un fonds
de capital-risque chinois mais derrière
on retrouve qui est bien l'américain
qualcomm en tout cas tout au début qui
était un des cofondateurs s'intéressa
parce que je vous en laisse ou ne
voulaient pas très très longtemps au
stade dragon texte limite ou qualcomm
dévoile son gros processeurs pour
smartphones notamment ya pas que ça
d'annoncé mais c'est vraiment la grosse
annonce pour l'année à venir et quel est
le smartphone en tout cas depuis
plusieurs années qui sera le premier
équipé du nouveau cela dragonne et bien
c'est toujours un smartphone de chez
tommy intéressant alors le troisième
secret c'est qu'au début j'ai omis
n'était pas du tout un fabricant de
smartphones c'était un studio de
développement d'applications pour
android et d'applications d'assistance
pour automobiles voyais on est un petit
peu loin des smartphones vendus en
millions et millions d'exemplaires dans
le monde entier dans le quatrième point
c'est les investissements café xiaomi
pour s'étendre en 2014 ils ont investi
205 millions de dollars dans
l'entreprise qui s'appelle mis des
acquis un constructeur spécialisé dans
l'électroménager pour développer tout un
écosystème et ben oui parce que xiaomi
en france on connaît beaucoup au travers
des smartphones des tablettes les télés
les trottinettes les mondes connectés
mais ya pas que ça en fait j'ai omis
vont faire beaucoup d'autres sur deux
aura effectivement des ampoules ya
tellement de choses il ya même des
bagages il ya des vêtements il ya des
peignoirs alors là on est un peu loin de
l'électroménager quand on parle de
peignoir mais xiaomi c'est un mastodonte
c'est un généraliste de la tech mais pas
que et en 2015 ils ont racheté la boîte
rigaud design qui est spécialisée dans
le design de produits high tech nous
emmène au cinquième secret ou connaît
aujourd'hui le site me.com et les
différentes déclinaisons qu'on a à
l'international sauf qu'au début be.com
ça leur appartenait absolument pas non
pas du tout ils ont fait le choix
d'acheter le domaine demi point com qui
existait déjà pour leur
internationalisation on revient donc ici
à 2014 et l'ont acheté plusieurs
millions de dollars c'est dire à quel
point êtes-vous là effectivement mis
point com et c'est depuis cette époque
on a commencé à appeler les smartphones
mais même si en 2021 on a arrêté les
appelé miksa a duré quand même quelques
années dans le 6ème secret c'est les
problèmes qu'ils ont rencontrés lors
leur internationalisation alors ils ont
attaqué différents marchés avant
d'arriver chez nous en france on 2018 et
en espagne en 2010 est qu'ils ont
attaqué d'autres marchés à savoir le
brésil l'inde la malaisie et compagnie
etc mais il ya quand même eu quelques
petits problèmes notamment par rapport à
la certification des smartphones dans
différents pays qui sont certifiés par
des entités gouvernementales
donc il fallait du temps ils ont pris du
retard ça leur a fait perdre quand même
pas mal de temps au niveau de leur
développement à l'international même si
in fine et ils y sont arrivés le
septième secret je trouve assez drôle
face et on vient en 2015 en malaisie et
à singapour shiomi s'est associé à
hubert pour vendre des smartphones
extrêmement rapidement vous allez sur
l'application vous commandiez votre
smartphone est il arrivé en quelques
minutes livré par un chauffeur vtc pour
être marrant si ça arrivait aujourd'hui
en france vous commandez par paf il est
livré par votre hubert bon pourquoi pas
aujourd'hui vous avez des boutiques
pouvez le commander le recevoir au moins
de 24 heures pour certains sites c'est
déjà pas mal le huitième secret c'est
une polémique qui a eu sur un vol de
données alors on revient ici à 2014
ainsi vraiment une histoire ancienne
alors je vous le dis c'est imam mbaye
elles étaient des logiciels espions
intégrer directement aux firmeware des
smartphones de l'époque en parle
vraiment de smartphones de l'époque ce
n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui on l'avait
notamment sur leurs ennemis notes et sur
leurs ennemis un ace qu'est-ce qu'ils
frc spyware et bien venez sauvegarder
automatiquement toutes vos données
personnelles vos photos vos vidéos vos
sms bref il sauvegarde et où est il le
faisait sur un serveur en chine il le
faisait parce que vous étiez connecter
en 3g mais lorsque vous étiez connecter
en wifi ça a été confirmé quelques mois
après par f secure est en fait je suis
aux miss a défendu été atteinte à temps
calmez vous c'est une fonctionnalité qui
s'appelle me claude mesaging qui sert à
sauvegarder vos données pour vous
puissiez avoir accès depuis votre
ordinateur et pouvoir taper des messages
directement au wifi sans devoir passer
par votre forfait téléphonique c'est ce
qu'on retrouvera aujourd'hui avec
imessage chez apple sauf que je suis au
miel ou beat faire un truc à l'époque et
bien c'est de demander le consentement
alors qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait à ce
moment là ils ont modifié les règles
elles ont demandé l'autorisation à
l'utilisateur de faire la sauvegarde et
la moindre des choses bon rassurez vous
cette histoire ancienne et tout est
clean aujourd'hui neuvièmes secret on va
parler de la répartition du chiffre
d'affaires que je trouve vachement
intéressante c'est des chiffres que j'ai
sur 2020 alors écoutez bien la vente de
smartphones et pc dans une grosse
enveloppe se représenter en 2020
61,9 pour cent de l'entreprise soit à
peu près 146 millions de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires rien que pour les
smartphones et les pc mais si on regarde
les objets connectés les produits
électroniques et les appareils
intelligents ça représente 27 4% c'est
énorme à savoir les télés les
vidéoprojecteurs les routeurs les
ampoules les trottinettes les moniteurs
les écouteurs les mots-clés
purificateurs d'air ou encore les
aspirateurs mais vous avez aussi pour
9,7 pour cent de prestation de services
internet à savoir des prestations de
services publicitaires et de l'édition
de contenus intéressants et puis après
il vous restera 1% 1% deux autres autres
on ne sait pas quoi mais en plus c'est
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans tous
types d'affaires global généré en 2020
et bien il y avait quand même plus de la
moitié 52% qui étaient réalisés en chine
pour 22000 74 employés une fois de plus
en 2020 c'est sans compter aujourd'hui
l'automobile qui commence à développer
du côté de chez au mit donc on sait que
le business de shiomi va continuer à
s'étendre et on verra ça dans les années
à venir bien évidemment et le dixième
secret c'est la culture de la start up
on part d'une start up créée en 2010 ils
ont toujours gardé chez chaumet cette
culture de la start up ils ont investi
dans différents bottes et il continue à
investir dans différentes start up qui
vont venir ensuite commercialisées sous
la marque xiaomi qu'on peut retrouver
dans différentes chez au mr donc le tout
quitte vachement intéressant on retrouve
notamment nine bottes dans lesquelles
ils sont yahoo a mis les smartphones
black shark bien qu'a priori il pourrait
être vendu mais ça c'est une autre
histoire il ya aussi une entreprise à
d'énergie juli qui a plein de boîtes
dans laquelle shiomi à placer ses billes
ça s'est assez mal alors je sais pas si
ce format de vidéo vous intéresse vous
voulez que je donne aussi d'autres se
créent d'autres matches pour être apple
ça pour être samsung s'apprête huawei ça
pourrait être beaucoup de marques dites
le moi en bas en commentaire ça vous
intéresse c'est ce que vous avez appris
des choses sur ces 10 secrets de xiaomi
est ce que vous les connaissiez ce que
vous en connaissez certains ce que vous
en connaissez d'autres si oui vous
pouvez marquer en bas aux commentaires
pour quand elle débarque ça c'est
vachement cool sur ce je vous invite à
me poser toutes vos questions bien
évidemment en bas et surtout à bien vous
abonner si c'est toujours pas le cas je
vous embrasse tous rendez vous très
rapidement pour continuer à parler tech
des bisous prenez soin de vous et yahoo
[Musique]